raymond les vacances nouveau nom nous
allons jouer le jeu dire bonsoir à nos
amis téléspectateurs et souligné que en
ce moment même vous êtes en vacances
sans doute moi je le suis peut-être
aussi j'en sais encore rien car nous
enregistrons cette émission et nous
sommes en réalité le combien comment
nous nous sommes le 19 juin 19 juin et
nous enregistrons cette émission pour la
période d'août je dis ça parce que nous
allons proposer une recette de glace or
si ça se trouve le jour de la diffusion
de cette émission il pleuvra peut-être
il frappe non non non il faut être
vous savez je voudrais que vous me
donnez le peuple à peu le petit demi
litre est au-dessous bhl ou que vous
cachez déjà tous des proches alors vous
savez comment il faut faire pour avoir
un quart de litre
un choeur de litres d'eau avec une avec
une mesure d'un demi litre alors on
regarde pas sa sacoche les deux bouts
voilà ça y est maeder vraiment savez
qu'il existe et vous voyez moi je n'en
ai pas alors je vais faire du sirop rio
on va faire de la glace et pour faire de
la glace on commence par mettre du sucre
dans une casserole de l'eau dans ce
sucre est également dans la casserole
bien entendu on a tout mélangé et nous
avons mis alors là je lundi que parce
que nous allons nous servir d'un pèse
siro qui est évidemment un grand
avantage
mais si on n'avait pas de prez siro il
serait néanmoins possible d'arriver à
faire des glaces de ce style là c'est à
dire des sorbets d'une façon à peu près
sûr car c'est ça la différence est en
effet les rassemblements cuite dans le
glacis classé dans la boîte
alors alors non jospeh si je fais le
sirop c'est à dire je laisse dissoudre
cette vie dans de l'eau très chaude sur
le feu 700 750 grammes de sucre pour un
quart de litre d'eau ceci n'étant que
pour le cas où nous n'aurions pas de
16,6
vaud un pain siro c'est absolument
unique n'a pas pris un demi litre deuil
a pris la moitié il n'a pas fait un
quart de litre d'eau il a pris la moitié
des militants y avait la moitié en
amérique alors ce que je pourrais faire
tout de suite c'est mettre à refroidir
ce sirop sur de la glace
soyez vous savez le passé est le passé
tout de suite mais pourquoi vous faites
ça pendant quatre ans et pourquoi vous
le passé parce que voyez-vous j'avais
chauffer la castre un tout petit peu
avant et il sait ce qu'il s'est passé
le phénomène habituel il se fait un peu
de caramel au froid à la casserole et
échoppes dans l'est libyen multiplie
dans ce récit commence alors je vais
refroidir ce sirop will et le plaisir
aux on pèse siro le voilà alors pour
peser weezy promesse de là je m'en vais
préparer le jus de fraise pour ceux ci
j'ai pris cinq cents grammes de ces 500
g de fraises je vais les mettre dans des
zones à pareille on ne dit pas soit
comme ceci oui vous les avez péché est
ce que vous avez péché blasé et bien
égouttés bien sûr essayer vous étiez le
but alors là vous croyez peut-être que
c'est une passion rassurez vous parce
que moi j'ai été missionné serrant bien
une passoire il ya un verre ou tout
oui les femmes du vote de samedi par
imagi bien sûr ce n'est pas les gentils
deutsch dernière ceux-ci console du
sirop ou blessure n'a pas l'importance
de tout à l'heure il faudra de toute
façon les mélanges et à la presse il est
parti il y en a une qui est parti je
vais la remplacer par des dons parce
qu'il y avait un compte
ah oui il y avait le poids c'était quoi
le poids le poids c'était 500 g 500
grammes et 750 grammes de sucre mais la
quantité de sucre n'a rien à voir vous
allez voir ce que ça donne ça ne lui oui
est-ce que jamais
pour vos frères
faire de la bouillie
voilà
et selon mes origines croyait à l'abri
vendays on n'ira pas jusqu'à
valenciennes après un petit appareil
bien on est amis on les écrase avec
voilà alors maintenant
vous laisse quand même de montrer que
vous pouvez vous débrouiller tout seul
déjà un titre à faire en fait ça va
aller très bien
voilà
voilà ça y est aussi haut
[Musique]
la télé maintenant je m'en vais pour
qu'ils ne restent plus du tout de jus de
fraise dans la passoire pendant quatre
non je n'en avais ajouter le sirop
dedans oui tu voulais vous ajoutez
verser le sirop dans la passoire
ça vous connais vous risquez pas les
yeux les y carrément l'élégant largement
bon encore un peu vite un stop
merci merci quatre laissez le sirop
affret non non non
[Musique]
expliquez vous ce que vous êtes un voile
à dire maintenant ça se termine et tout
ça c'est terminé je vous commandez bars
et merci alors je m'en vais maintenant
mélangez ici le sirop de fraise la pulpe
de fraise de la pub ce n'est pas de
sitôt
c'est de la pub je m'en vais la mélanger
avec du sirop que j'ai refroidi en
partie continuer à refroidir ce mélange
et si oui mais vous allez voir dans la
série maintenant alors c'est de ce côté
que ce à quoi bon voilà je voulais vous
faire couler je vous prie éclaté il ya
un côté qui est fait pour faire couler
l'autre c'est merci store alors
maintenant se mélangent que nous venons
d'obtenir et où ne rentrerait plus dans
le vert c'est pourquoi je le perds en
dehors alors j'avais besoin de
changement ou où voulez vous que vous le
maître pour que l'on puisse bien voir le
pen siro alors je remplis ou à peu près
croyez vous et puis je vais mettre le ps
siro dedans à ce moment là je vais
mettre des lunettes pouvoir ou de quoi
il s'agit parce que sans les lunettes je
n'y vois rien qui nous ce que c'est
qu'un paiement et bien voyez vous je
suis tombé pile du premier coup seul le
pèze siro me permet de connaître le
degré bomin du mélange alors nous devons
obtenir environ 18 degrés beau mais pour
le mail à nous la loue les avons à peu
près exactement à peu près un degré près
ce n'est pas grave c'est pourquoi
lorsque l'on n'a pas ce matériel
nécessaire c'est à dire ce qu'il appelle
zizanie papon se mélanger par moitié si
vous voulez alors là nous avons une
sorbetière
alors je vais mettre le jus nouvelle
vous en aller sans prévenir autrement
dit pour réaliser cette fois c'est
absolument oui oui pro tu ne sembles
même archaïques comme celle ci
l'apal importance pourvu qu'il y ait une
longue plongée dans vos greniers
plongeant les douaniers et retiré en
1921 pour vous et qui pleurait alors
compléter le puzzle
ça va c'est ronnie de d'un d'installer
votre système
vous avez alors partir de maintenant
j'ai mis le sirop à l'intérieur des
ternes et je mets de la glace a dit qu
on peut mettre à gaspiller bien entendu
ce sera vraisemblablement payant du sel
à la plupart d'entre vous de la glace
pilée
parce qu'on n'a pas couramment n'avait
sont tout à l'heure vous reviendrez à ce
qu'on fait lorsqu'on a pas de faits siro
vous serez gentil parce que l'éolien m'a
bien eu lieu mais j'y reviendrais dû cn
la glace du c'est exactement
et vous avez-vous précisément pour
répondre à prédit d'ailleurs aux
personnes qui n'ont pas de répugnance et
aux mêmes qui aiment le sorbet de ceux
qui aiment le sorbet et préparé de cette
façon là ce qui est tout de même très
différentes aux différents opus ce qui
est bien légitime
voilà leur dites moi si je ne m'abuse
c'est assez loin
bien sûr les poêlons il est donc
largement le temps d'avoir la glace
terminé accord
voir tout le temps va durer ce plan dans
le mettre en route pour être sûr que
l'ensemble bavière mortier qui mobilise
pour sauver sa rappelle les anciens
les serveurs la casser alors maintenant
nous devrions demander à notre aide
nous fermons z occupé de tourner
alors maintenant catherine nous allons
parler des glaces qui se pose de la même
manière nous allons revenir un tout
petit peu sur les méthodes les meilleurs
ayo et sortir tout ça parce que ça me
paraît
oui et alors vous allez revenir au
fessier pages sont restées près du site
aussi besoin de l'entendement xing faire
sa fête annuelle du bruit oui voilà
alors alors il y a une chose que j'ai
oublié mais ce n'est pas très grave
je le mettrais tout à l'heure c'est du
jus de citron pour relever un tout petit
peu la rome des fraises mais c'est pas
grave on va se bagarrer
après ça je mettrai donc le jus de
citron en même temps qu'un blanc d'oeuf
battu mais ceci au bout d'un moment
quand la glace sera pratiquement prise
alors nous allons parler de glace du
même style c'est à dire de sorbet alors
je vais revenir sur la question tout de
suite du sirop si vous n'avez pas de
payer ce qu'ils en pensent
vous obtenez un sirop à 30 degrés en
mouillant c'est à dire en mettant un
quart de litre d'eau dans 750 grammes
dessus pratiquement ça donne du 30
degrés si vous mesurez par quantité
égale le jus de fruit et le sirop vous
le doublé en trente ans degré bonnet à
peu près et vous obtenez un sirop qui
est pratiquement autour de 15
c'est un tout petit peu faible pour une
glace mais c'est acceptable entre 15 et
18 degrés on peut on peut faire de la
glace de très bonne qualité
alors donc voyez vous il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas de comment dirais-je possible des
possibilités alors là nous allons vous
faire voir comment on fait la glace
aussi content il se fait exactement
comme la grâce aux freins
oui ça fait beaucoup alors voir voler
quelques endroits de service suivant
mais moins d'heures partir avec ça un
peu plus loin
oui vous trouvez qu elles sont bien vous
allez intervenir dans quelques secondes
elles sont gentilles de travailler ainsi
et encore elles se font chasser et assez
vite parce que j'avais besoin peau alors
ici voyez vous je vais vous faire voir
comment on prépare un citron pour être
fait un citron givré
on fait des oranges et des citron givré
de vous en faire voir d'ailleurs nous
avons fait nous l'avons fait avant
l'émission et ceci a une certaine
importance
oui parce que je crois qu'on aime
beaucoup cela c'est très décoratif en
plus et mon dieu nous et envers la gent
temps de faire de le découper
d'une certaine façon voilà pour enlever
le couvercle aurelio mois ci l'a alors à
ce moment là avec une cuillère tout ce
qu'il ya de plus ordinaire comme ceux ci
on vient on marque la pulpe comme
ceux-ci du site on remarque la pulpe
quand on enlève la totalité d'un pull
qu'on ne garde que les corps cette
opération on la refait ici la même façon
en faisant attention de ne pas abîmer là
il ne veut pas crever le site on sait
d'autant que possible ce n'est pas d'une
gravité absolue parce que d'abord on
peut refaire des pièces on peut mettre
une pièce dire ah kow media center coin
alors et audax et marquer quand ceux-ci
entoure et puis on enlève voyons là
alors on garde le citron et royaux le
cas qui viennent se produire
j'ai effectivement fait un trop fort
coucou alors je prendrai comme ceux ci
une petite lame de citron sur nord et
royaux le fond et le parena
intérieur alors ceci on le coupe en
beaucoup de petits morceaux comme ceci
de façon à pouvoir réaliser le jus de la
même façon que j'ai réalisé le jus tout
à l'heure avec un pot pour les fraises
n'est ce pas c'est exactement pareil non
je ne vais pas le faire et je voulais
dire que l'on peut le faire si ça voilà
alors de la même manière d'un même
manière alors maintenant je voudrais
qu'on fait le sirop c'était à faire
exactement pareil aussi on peut en
parler même base exactement 750 g de
sucre en quart de litre d'eau au mélange
avec qu'avec le jeudi 30 langues indiqué
le maire la même chose là vous allez
faire un blandin alors là je vais monter
en honneur
la différence c'est que c'est le
contraire c'est ici que doit peut-être
le blanc est là le genre regardez
oui le regarder je m'en servir tout à
l'heure alors je vais prendre deux
blancs d'être pour la facilité de
l'opération mais en réalité inspirée un
seul suffirait un blanc d'oeuf et c'est
ce qui est de faire nos ça n'aide pas
mais ça fait une glace beaucoup plus
moelleuse beaucoup plus joli et c'est
très important
alors la relève et je vais aussi faire
du bruit je vais monter également mais
il n'est pas utile que le blanc d'oeuf
soit montrée très ferme
il suffit qu'il soit montré pour sa part
pour donner à vos premières amours je
reviens à mes premières amours
pendant que j'aime bien les petits
appareils maintenant que je sais me
servir de huit ans après on a fait ça va
c'est pas impossible tout arrive
je sais que c'est monsieur biya qui
n'aime pas mes lunettes
mais c'est pas mal ça fait des reflets
quand j'entends dans le lointain que ça
mais on pourrait revenir avec tout ça
oui d'ailleurs de toute façon il faut
réveiller parce que pour que je mette le
jus de citron et le glandeur à la volée
ou le glandeur n'a pas besoin d'être
très faire il faut qu'il soit monté
comme ceux ci bien monsieur
les nouvelles sont bonnes bah alors je
vais revoir la crème glacée voilà le
blanc d'oeuf le jus de citron le faux
etc et là je vous prie 4 le premier
présente ses profits n'est pas de celles
qui lui se rentrer à l'intérieur de la
glace voilà alors maintenant je vais
ouvrir la sorbetière
j'espère que lyon a toujours alors je
vais d'enlever le couvert ouvert fait un
tout petit peu coincé voilà vous faire
très attention
rio alors laver le couvercle alors léger
parfum l'espace est absolument parfait
c'est presque suffisant d'ailleurs alors
je vais même on va le voir tout à
l'heure alors et vous je mens le blanc
d'oeuf
je vais mettre le jus d'un citron
environ voilà je remets l'appareil en
place c'est pourquoi vous évitant
toujours je les avais pour laisser
tomber du ciel des soldats s'ils sont
mauvais remarqué j'ai jamais essayé
aussi hélas a volontairement
volonté en vain voilà si vous avez la
gentillesse mettant à dos tourné pendant
deux ans restait deux minutes ça soit
pas bon et bien parti tout seul un seul
est incroyable des gentilles leur
exemple voilà des citrons et des hommes
qui ont été livrés pas plus que ça si
oui alors le dolent offert là nous
allons vous voulez voir me donner la
glace qui vient il ya un peu de glace
dans le dans le réfrigérateur
c'est ça qu'a pris qui a été fait dans
les mêmes conditions qui a été fait
exactement la même production soit gelée
blanche c'est la glace au titre ont fait
part de façon à ce qu'elle soit plus
mieux visible en quelques temps il l'aps
et là c'est le même
la même manière que vous avez exactement
absolument est exactement comme en farsi
6 7 6 et soirée avant de le remettre à
l'intérieur de l'élément du
réfrigérateur où il prend cette petite
allure givré
c'est ça tout autour blanchi vincent
riou alors là je remets le couvert au
dessus du port
je prends ici un tout petit peu de pâte
d'amande jeu modèle de feuilles
comme vous pouvez voir l'autre côté
[Musique]
alors lol encore faire autre chose nous
allons garnir
si vous voulez bien ici deux assiettes
non que le quotidien compte plus que 3 6
la sécurité interne en réalité je sais
que vous êtes un méchoui euros et bien
voilà je voudrais vous faire voir
comment on peut décorer comme ceci alors
à l'aide depuis que pourri alors on voit
une serait une vraie aujourd'hui il a
des petits effets amusants d'un carton
rouge et on fit que ceux ci comme ceci
si vous êtes vous amuser co2 de ses
modèles soient là alors on peut comme
ceux ci de phares et les quantités de
décors variés vous voilà et la glace
comme ceux ci paul une allure très joli
dans le décor mais j'ai délaissé de
traverser le boyau
je n'ai pas le noyau nucléaire mais dans
fin sous peu à la pomme s'arrêter oui
ah bah ça y est vous remercie et vous
donne des envies et bien récemment
revoir à nos anges descendent de
charmantes jeunes filles qui sont ces si
je crois oui elle s'en suit celle ci ou
sur la suisse dans notre corps nos
studios
ça fait pas de corps juno m'excuser à
cette exposition
mais beckham dise si vous voyez
sursauter c'est que je la alors ça c'est
terminé
l'opération inverse à tout à l'heure
actuelle toujours pareil c'est un peu
coincée elle a décoincé la tête et voilà
alors là je pourrai le faire on va
repartir d'ici la glace mais jamais avec
la sortie et la messe dans l'ain
alors là aussi je voudrais laver ça
allait au cours pas bien il risque d'y
avoir du sel toujours alors c'est une
véritable cuisine pour les âmes 1 pouces
est aujourd'hui c'est pas pour dire mais
vous êtes agité remuant vous allez dans
tous les sens
voilà c'est fini même si pat misch âge
encore plus loin je vous promets je
pouvais finir en attendant gilbert il
alors japonais a promis voilà voilà la
glace nous venons de faire ça y est vous
qui êtes très faire et sa vélocité
difficile ah oui on va on peut la moule
et la remettre à sangler en forme d'un
amour ou bien simplement dans des
tiroirs il y en a derrière moi si vous
voulez monter d'été des tiroirs de
réfrigérateur tout à fait à droite
catherine c'est gentil à vous ça je vous
signale que ça plaît beaucoup aux
enfants
john sasi si oui c'est exact la voilà la
glace est un sorbet à la fraise qui a
été légèrement citronnée et en a mis
deux blancs de da pour la quantité de un
bon litre
ça vous a paru non pas d'en faire un
seul blanc ce jus clients qu'elle essaie
pour la rendre plus obtient cependant
que je sais que ce côté un peu brillant
que ceux ciblant des landes
alors voyez vous nous avons ici un
sorbet aux fraises ici un sorbet au
citron l'auront des citrons et des
oranges givré vous avez vu comment très
vite avec une avec un peu de pâte
d'amande
j'ai fait des feuilles enfin ça c'est au
bout de chacun l'epic fou et ça c'est
également au goût de chacun
la technique une fois que l'on a garni
voyez-vous qu'on me l'ait fait tout à
l'heure le citron après l'avoir et
vidéos l'oranje après l'avoir vidée et
de les remettre dans le l'évaporateur
d'individus du réfrigérateur c'est à
dire la partie où habituellement se
forment les cubes de glace alors là le
citron ou d'orange pas ce côté givré que
vous le voyez ce que ce livre qui est
dessus très jolie et très joli et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi on l'appelle reason
ici alors on les sort comme un service
regardez il ya un moment il ya déjà le
port indien qui a pratiquement 2
millions qu'on leur sortie ils sont
encore en parfait état et avons encore
le coup un bon moment commence malgré la
chaleur du studio qui est quand même
très suffisante
voyez la glace d'ailleurs que nous avons
fait alors je voudrais peut-être demandé
à catherine de nous donner sans son
impression sur cette glande impression
c'est que c'est froid savait pas à cet
excellent ça surtout un merveilleux vous
de sauver la même écoute fruits parce
que c'est fait avec des fruits frais aux
quotas il n'y a pas de norme il n'y a
pas de solution de continuité c'est fait
d'un seul coup et je crois que c'était
très très bon je crois que ça y est nous
avons 10 1/2 litre de sirop à 30 degrés
en 2000 litres de jus de fruits font en
litres de crème en litres facile parce
que il y as we le
neuf qui fait qui fait mousser un tout
petit peu et puis aussi le jus de citron
il fait du volume alors ça fait
pratiquement litre et demi de sorbet ce
litre et demi de sorbet on peut très
bien le mouler dans un moule à sorbet et
le remettre à sangler et c'est à dire
vous bien même tout simplement dans les
tiroirs de réfrigérateurs et le laisser
comme cela où il ne bougera pas au frais
on peut aussi garnir des fruits avec on
peut garnir des coupes on peut s'amuser
tant que l'on veut il nous reste à
espérer maintenant que le jour de la
diffusion de cette émission est dans la
période qui suivra quand vous saurez
faire les sorbets vient le temps soit
beau et chaud n'est ce pas parce que
même si je le souhaite avec appelée val
été
[Musique]